ambulance emeriti I was talking to Jen
yesterday Jen Schiffer said well what I
really want to know is polymer or
parallax have you ever picked a
framework or library or stat and got
this
a couple years ago some co-workers and I
went to a place called Del Taco
I don't know if you have those outside
of Utah but we have del tacos and he
ordered a burger with just it was really
hard to get the order out and he said
well I just want like ketchup and a
pickle on it
I don't like the cheese and all that
kind of stuff he opens it up you know it
gets as a ketchup in a pickle I went
back and got the burger but uh sometimes
when we compare all of these libraries
or frameworks or toolkits or whatever
name they want to give themselves we
sometimes think that they're equivalent
to each other or more similar than maybe
we realized that they are or aren't so
if you boil down browser development I
think you've got these five tasks
involved and I hope that this is a
pretty unbiased list of you're building
something in the browser here's what you
have to consider so you've got to
interact with data stores maybe it's
like a JSON API maybe it's just
something to local storage or maybe it's
some over WebSockets but you've got some
data store somewhere that you deal with
you want to render that data to the UI
and keep it up to date and you need to
respond to user interaction to go and
change things and you need to deal with
routing and URLs so that we don't
continue to break the web like most of
us have done for the last few years and
we need to do project stuff where do the
files go what do we name them do use
underscores dashes camelcase
what if you're on unix and guys on Mac
and now your capitalization is wrong but
it works on your computer but not
there's that kind of stuff and also the
build so I framed this whole talk around
these five tasks and then addressed what
each of the ambulatory bone libraries
are concerned about not necessarily what
they are the best at or whose API is
better for the task but just how
concerned is the library with one of
these tasks so here's my graph no
surprise amber is very concerned about
everything I took out a few columns like
your clothes your opinion on MongoDB
things like that so you can see ember is
very concerned about everything angular
is concerned to some degree with all of
these acceptor project stuff react in
polymer just right up the middle and
then a backbone has probably the
strangest looking graph on there and
also for all these comparisons my
favorite UI that I build is a
master-detail UI you think about any
application that has any significance in
your life and it's going to have some
sort of master detail so that's where
you've got two lists on the left and
then some items on the right so let's
look at what we've got here so here is
the app that I built in all five of
these libraries so on the Left we have a
list and as we click through the list
it changes the person on the right I get
an active link here I can refresh this
and it should still work I can come to
Matt and I should be able to click back
and that should all work I edit Matt
Matthew save it and it should update
here update here and it's actually going
off to a server side API so those were
those changes in that edit should be
reflected when i refresh here as well so
those are the that's the the baseline
for how I'm comparing all of these
things for the code samples and the rest
of it now but on master detail
think about your UI you probably have
this even if it's just like the global
navigator at least on the left go inside
there there's another list and just one
little piece of your app is changing at
a time while all the wrapper stuff on
the outside is not so let's look at
backbone so I I ranked at 0 to 4 and how
concerned it is not how good it is at it
but how concerned it is with the problem
so data backbone gave a to rendering
nothing user action routing in project
so here is backbones own definition of
what it is
backbone gives structured to web
applications by providing models with
key value binding and custom events
collections with the rich API for a
numeral function enumerable functions
use with declarative event handling and
connects it all to your existing API
over restful Jason interface so not a
whole lot of like tag learn there but
just very here's what I give you
I sent out a questionnaire to the
creators of all these libraries and this
was my response from Jeremy I was gonna
have a slide for each question and but
anyway Jeremy I don't want to like be
talking bad about Jeremy Jeremy had a
huge influence on probably all of us and
a lot of us are still using underscore
CoffeeScript 2012 was like the year of
Jeremy right and he did a lot of great
things for all of us so data how does it
handle data it's got backbone model it's
probably the most interesting part of
the library it works great with a lot of
rest ish
API is right out of the box but when it
doesn't it's super easy to just back out
and change some things and you got
pub/sub to connect those models to your
view rendering and then you have decide
to have collections and all of this
stuff gets cached so when you request
some records it's going to stay in that
collection and then we ask for one of
those items back from that collection
you get the same object that the whole
collection has which makes updating
things a little bit easier
rendering doesn't do anything backbone
view prototype render is a no op so in
order to get anything on the page at all
and backbone you've got to do something
yourself so you have brains in your head
you have feet in your shoes you can
steer yourself any direction you choose
you're on your own and you know what you
know and you are the one will decide
where to go most people do this at least
the demos
I've seen a lot more handlebars in the
wild and then I guess you could do
manual Dom and actually a new thing a
lot of people are mixing up backbone and
react and having a rack do the rendering
for them and then just using backbone
for the models and collections user
interaction so it's interesting that
backbone doesn't provide anything for
rendering but it does provide user
interaction so you have a declarative
select handler configuration to select
an element and then handle the event
routing it's got a router I only ranked
it at a1 because all it really does is
Maps some route to some Handler and then
that's it and then you have some
programmatic api's to navigate around
the app but it doesn't have any like
declarative routing or links to
automatically get their href set you
have to control all of the setup and
teardown during transitions there isn't
actually even a concept of a transition
so if you want to stop or cancel or
retry some sort of route there's nothing
in there so you've got to build out
yourself
project stuff you're on your own
backbone played a really critical role
we probably have all used it most of us
so I have like a little special place in
my heart for backbone for getting
everyone to actually start taking the
browser even more seriously than we had
started to and jQuery and other things
showed up so let's look at the code
really fast and backbone to make that
thing happen so I've got my index with
some ejs templates hope that's big
enough I can make it bigger so I'm
getting my models in here and just
calling things on a template is probably
the least interesting part here total
lines of code I was down at about 200 so
stuff that I had to write because
backbone didn't provide anything for me
I had to tell it how you actually render
anything into the browser and then a
little thing called serialized so this
is an interesting thing about backbone
is usually you get someone else's flavor
of backbone because it doesn't someone
in the hot tub last night said the
backbone gives you
enough rope to hang yourself and that's
and then that's it so you got to get you
got to get the rest in there yourself
the models almost worked with my API
I had to assign this parse thing to
extract route which then will pull out
you know like the root key that some
api's give you actually had to handle
the click events on links to be able to
route around through the app myself and
so any link that is not external I'm
going to grab that and then tell
backbone history to move around and
notice there I didn't program in any way
to like prevent a transition from
happening so user has a form half filled
out and then they click some link
somewhere else in old development you
have on before and load to alert and say
hey you're not done with this form are
you sure
but with my little implementation here
I'm on my own and then to set up the
models to my API is pretty quick that
was that's about it back phone model
here define a couple things and then my
collection also very very simple and
then you get into the view stuff don't
really want to talk a whole lot about
this because this is just my idea of how
backbone can render a view but basically
I have a router that has a couple mapped
routes here contact and then edit and
then the app and contact are two things
and it was kind of kind of tricky to
keep the Left column
around that but only change the stuff in
the right since backbone isn't
prescribing anything to me I had to
figure that all all out on my own so all
in all yeah there's the app not bad but
a lot of work I've been doing backbone
for two years at work and I couldn't
believe I've like I'm not a very good
developer still because it took me way
longer to do the back on one than any of
the others
alright so that's enough about backbone
oh it's not enough about backbone what's
really neat about backbone is you can
use it like anywhere
if you've used Testim before their
little interface inside of the console
is actually using backbone to create
this tab interface inside of a CLI I
think that's really slick you can't do
that with most the other things that
I'll be talking about ok angular this is
the new kid on the block that has seemed
to like take over everything at least in
my city they had the conference there in
Salt Lake and we've got I got a lot of
friends that are really big into angular
superhero JavaScript mvw
w stands for whatever lets you extend
HTML vocabulary for your app it's a tool
set for building a framework most suited
to your application development
misko says he wanted to make it easy for
web designers non developers to build
web apps I didn't know that they had a
firebase back-end idea at first but they
dropped that what development problems
does it solve decouple your DOM and
testing is right there as one of their
first things and then creating dsls
in HTML well features are you excited
about directives so you can make your
own DSL directives are pretty neat
especially at the composition with them
so then ask them for a sales pitch said
angular is the web what the web browser
would have been had it been designed for
dynamic applications rather than static
documents and by the angular team
so rendering I added that last part the
UI stays up-to-date with the magical
scope object so it's interesting that
Mitsuko says that it was designed for
designers because if you think about
that scope object and you think about
CSS if you say color red the color is
red and that's how scope works you say
scope name is Ryan and name is Ryan when
it wherever I changed that it's just
going to update so I think that this is
one of the greatest things about angular
is you really can just hand it to
someone who doesn't have a whole lot of
experience with browser development and
just say here's this dollar scope thing
put whatever you want on it whenever you
want and this thing is going to stay up
to date for you so it gives people a
real rush of like just enthusiasm and
excitement for building stuff in the
browser that they haven't had probably
their entire career in the web composing
attribute directives is also pretty
powerful if you wanna make something
draggable and have a tooltip you just
have to attribute directives you just
give them some attributes on your HTML
element and you get that behavior so you
can compose those together really well
but essentially it's just a whole bunch
of directives that are hooks based on
the name of an element or they attribute
on the element that gives us some
behavior so yeah I think their HTML DSL
is really good the scope API is
fantastic
the directive API is completely nuts
I really like I don't understand this
stuff
but anyway people people like building
directives
I think the API that you get from it
it's really really good data I hope I
gave it a tune out of one it gives you
HTTP which is really just an xhr module
so the scope stuff will get up-to-date
automatically for you if you do anything
outside of angular's like blest modules
you've probably got a call scope apply
to get their dirty checking which is the
way that they keep the UI up-to-date to
happen and so HTTP will do that for you
automatically and then resource is a
declarative model like module to hook up
an API to an HTTP API but it's very
limited in that like it's expecting xhr
calls and like puts and posts and get
you couldn't really twist it very well
into other things like local storage or
stuff like that so that's why it's only
a two instead of like a four where maybe
they would provide something to allow
you to plug into any kind of data store
user interaction st. paradigm is
rendering just use the HTML scope so you
add functions onto scope and then you
put an attribute on your element to like
on click or ng click will then call some
function note no delegation of all the
events live on the elements routing I
only gave it a 2 because it has ng view
which is pretty nice you can just say
what these routes render this controller
in this template into this ng view but
it's limited because you can't do any
sort of nesting so in my example I've
got stuff on the left thing on the right
and you can't you can't do another level
with ng view so the UI router a lot of
you out there thinking yet just use UI
router and so you can't and UI routers
pretty good and in angular 2.0 they're
redoing the grounder completely I don't
know if they're still looking at ember
but they were looking at embers router
so ice project stuff you're on your own
you know what you know and you're the
one who'll decide where you go let's go
to the yeah let's go to the code for
thank you there real quick so angular
not very much that's the whole app I
didn't really have to do anything custom
they've got a route provider thing to do
my routing and the big angular resource
that I plugged into my API with just
this quick little config I make my
controllers and just dump stuff on to
scope which is super super easy and then
my edit controller was not too bad the
only kind of weird thing was to keep the
stuff on the left up to date I had to do
pub/sub so I edit the thing publishing
event comes back up and then I just
refresh all the contacts from the server
there'd be a much better way to do that
I'm sure but angular didn't really
direct me on how to do something like
that so I had to go for it myself all
right so next up we have polymer polymer
if you're not familiar with it is
basically a partially a polyfill for
using the new stuff that's coming out in
the web so web components mostly from
their website polymer puts elements back
at the center of web development you can
create your own HTML elements and
compose them into complete complex
applications that are scalable and
maintainable data they don't do anything
for data you're on your own routing they
don't do anything for outing and do
anything for project stuff complex
applications that are scalable and
maintainable with just elements it's me
anyway surrendering everything is an
element it actually uses the shadow down
when available which is super weird for
your CSS because if you like have some
class names on your elements in
application elements you have to import
that CSS to every single one of those
elements for it to apply they two-way
bind the properties so if you pass in a
property to an element and then you
change the outside of that element
somewhere it's going to stay up to date
in the element and vice versa if you
change that property inside the element
outside the element is gonna stay up to
date and it's just declarative this is
that and you're done
you have published properties so you
have more granular control of what the
outside world can pass in just like
normal elements they don't respond to
some types of attributes and a really
nice mustache syntax for content and
attributes you just drop in the
mustaches into anywhere in the template
and they will work user interaction use
a declarative events just like the other
ones so far and they just map to methods
on the component definition so very
similar of good distinction is polymer
versus the platform so the lowest layer
of polymer is platform jeaious and that
contains all the libraries that are the
polyfills
but then polymer itself has like some
stuff on top of that so when you're
doing polymer you're not actually like
doing the future of the web web
components you've got that but you also
are using a polymer library built on top
of it so it's not exactly what's going
to be a web component ship
I think HTML imports is one of the most
interesting parts of all of this you
think about bringing bootstrap into your
application or any sort of library that
has CSS and JavaScript with HTML imports
this is what it would be to bring
bootstrap into your app and you're done
because that bootstrap HTML file could
have the CSS and it could have the
JavaScript all your dependencies become
declarative HTML knows how to load HTML
it knows how to load JavaScript and it
knows how to load CSS and so it's
actually I'll playing around with this
and it was it was a ton of fun to be
able to just make an HTML file and
import it and you don't need a build but
you could throw a build at it of course
let's look at the polymer code so here's
all my so you have a polymer element so
I got to import my stuff bring in
contacting it those are elements that I
use inside of here you define your
template like I said here with each one
of these I had to import this style
sheet which felt kind of annoying but it
worked fine a little bit like angular
here template repeat this will repeat
something in there my routing I had no
idea what to do for routing so I did
this total hack where I said
hidden if the route isn't index and then
I'll show it and this one's hidden if
it's not contact addy addy looked at my
code last night and he didn't make any
changes with the routing so I guess I
did an okay job I don't know here is a
hundred lines of stuff that I had to
write that it didn't provide for me so I
made a little xhr thing I had to make my
own router which is not too bad I just
made a really quick little junky one and
then a contacts tour to fetch and deal
with my API so hundred lines of my own
code and then inside of each of these
you have your polymer elements and as
you can see my app element I set up my
router etc so it's kind of fun that one
felt the strangest of all of them to
build for me anyway but I'm really
excited about polymer ember the whole
rainbow this is the one I'm most
familiar with I use this all the time
and I'm actually pretty involved with
ember very simple marketing it
incorporates common idioms so you can
focus on what makes your app special
here's why Tom created it you know the
browser is getting competitive
developers didn't have the tools or even
sometimes the vocabulary to take
advantage of that what does it solve
manages complexity as the size of your
application and the team building it
increases so get rid of boilerplate
pushing the right direction it provides
correct answers for your questions
instead of being on your own it's most
excited about the router and the router
is awesome common misconceptions
documentation is hard it's actually very
well documented now getting started is
hard it's not nearly as hard as it used
to be and in some cases super easy to
get started
favorite website is Viacom using ember I
run out of time so I'm going to cruise
through the sales pitch there so routing
this is are going to the best part of
the app you can have nested routes and
those couple - nested views and so doing
a master-detail
and then doing a master-detail inside of
there is the very same you don't have to
change anything we're in all
the other code examples that I had to do
one more level I would have had to
change all my architecture routes have a
ton of a ton of functionality you can
pause retry cancel transitions you get
declarative links to other places and
from experience it is a lot harder to
break the URL than to support it number
rendering
it's got bound templates it's actually
very much like polymer yeah sometimes it
can be a little bit slow with handlebars
but HTML bars coming out it's gonna make
it a lot faster user interaction same as
some of the other ones you got the
declarative events in your HTML that
mapped to actions on your controllers
and views and routes but you also get
impaired of viewing component events so
if you need to drop down to that level
sometimes it's a lot more convenient or
just a better place to do your events
imperative ly rather than always having
them in your templates also event
handlers are free in ember you can add a
thousand of them and it's not an expense
because everything's just delegated so
there's one click handler for the entire
app data amber data is a separate live
live library so you not to use it but
it's got model serialize and adapter so
that you can custom so you can connect
any sort of API into ember data be able
to serialize how you need to be able to
talk to some service with an adapter how
you need to it's also got an in-memory
cache so when you ask for the same for
an object by some ID you get that same
object every single time you ask for it
which makes keeping things up-to-date
easy and the ships with two adapters
that a lot of people can use
out-of-the-box project stuff ember CLI
it's the thing that creates a
boilerplate project for you gives you
prescribe file organization and tests
build deploy tools generators lots of
stuff so amber cares about all the
things so let's look at the amber code
number was the shortest one that's a
assault on fifty-three lines of code and
if you look inside of here everything is
actually just very declarative I just
say here's my host for my rest service
here are that she beats on my model
here on my routes I have a contact route
in an edit route and they mapped to
these paths
mber is unique in that it tells you how
to provide data to your templates so
like it like tom was saying in that
quote like it's giving us a vocabulary
about these kinds of things sent in your
contact route I just tell it find that
contact and in these two routes here
contact an edit route I'm going to get
the same object in both of them
and then just a little action here to
save it'll say if in a transition to a
different route so amber had everything
that I needed to build this UI in
structure we call developing with ember
whiplash driven development it gives you
so much and you go so fast for two weeks
and you forget that like this isn't just
how your life is and then BAM you hit
something and you get extra angry at
ember because you were going so fast
where if you're going a normal speed you
wouldn't get so angry at it so react
this is a new I guess it's like a year
old now right most people are using
react for the V and MVC it uses a Dom
diff for high performance but you can
also do service under a drink because of
this Dom diff and instead of having two
way binding it has a one-way reactive
data flow so data just flows down
through your app and the goal is there
to make your app easier to reason about
Pete is saying basically that it was
really hard to set up all those
observers so they wanted to do it
automatically and they ended up with
react I'll let you use plain old
JavaScript to express your UI at any
point in time rather than some in this
initial state and then update that state
as things change most excited about the
composition and that render is treated
like a black box for me personally it
has felt a lot like server-side
rendering where you get a request you
get some data
you build HTML and then you're done and
then you're out you don't have like this
I set up this house of cards and now I
pulled out this piece
oh no the whole thing fell apart just
refresh and then it's back to normal so
they're trying to get rid of that key
value observation state web of things
with react a couple common
misconceptions JSX is the least
interesting part of react JSX is
basically xml in your javascript rather
than javascript in your template you go
the other way I love using JSX
it's a harmless declarative language
dump it into the imperative one feels
great the virtual Dom is about treating
your render like a black box it's not
about performance it's favorite website
the uses is facebook.com/ of course
wants to keep his job here's a sales
pitch expression UI at any point in time
data buying has problems with
composition and react is the most
expressive way to build user interfaces
data doesn't give you anything you're on
your own routing doesn't give you
anything project stuff nothing rendering
is it's just it's such a different
paradigm I encourage you guys to go
there all of you to go try it out and
play with it it's one of the things
where if you read about it it's not
quite the same as actually experiencing
it I can tell you about some really
delicious salsa that my wife and I make
but until you actually taste it you
won't really know what I'm talking about
our tikka masala though is awful but
everything feels like input/output right
it feels like functions you want to
build some sort of SVG icon you make a
function that returns some XML and
you're done this is actually really good
right here a very good example of how to
express your UI
you've got props that come in you have
these things that make elements that go
out filter it sort of slice that map but
return some divs and you're done so it's
pretty interesting
and user inaction declarative dislike
everything else so some of my thoughts
amber and angular obviously give you the
most and you don't have to read a whole
lot of your own code so if you don't
want to be writing a bunch of your own
stuff then you probably want to pick one
of those if you want to do other things
and you enjoy writing your own things
those other things are great options
thank you